en attendant voici les développements
les autres titres de l'actualité en
commençant par une image symbole image
d'espoir et de paix aussi cet après midi
devant l'ex ambassade d'iran à paris les
proches de marcel carton et de marcel
fontaine deux des otages français au
liban ont témoigné simplement témoignage
émouvant pour dénoncer trois ans de
détention
trois ans de violation des principes
d'humanité les plus élémentaires
philippe gassot pour les trois années
terribles des trois otages français
trois colombes et trois femmes devant
l'ambassade d'iran un geste symbolique
pour que personne n'oublie
pas de foule juste la fille la femme et
la soeur
on est révolté l'attendre
et trois ans et c'est énorme on est venu
ici parce que maintenant le gouvernement
iranien dit qu'il peut nous aider alors
puisqu'il peut nous aider qu'il le fasse
vite
ces trois ans de douleurs des tristesses
nous qui sommes en liberté c'est dur
pour nous c'est très lourd pour eux je
me demande comment ils vont nous revenir
après trois ans de captivité les otages
français au liban et tous les autres
n'ont toujours pas été libérés pour le
moment inlassable l'espoir de trois
femmes demeure le caire